hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video i want
to demonstrate how to dawn and doff
personal protective equipment also known
as PPE before donning PPE you want to
make sure you select the appropriate
personal protective equipment and this
is based on the potential infectious
agent that your patient has plus you
want to pick the right size of PPE you
want to make sure that you are following
the sequence set by your hospital's
protocols in this video I'm going to
demonstrate just one of the possible
sequences you can use to put on PPE so
one of the sequences you can use the pin
on PPE would be first to put on the gown
followed by the mask or respirator
depending on what you're going to use
then the goggles or face shield and then
lastly the gloves and you will Don this
PPE before you enter the patient care
area first perform hand hygiene then put
the gown on by sliding it up the arms
and insert the thumbs into the thumb
inserts of the gown if present this
particular gown has a loop that can be
placed over your head then secure the
gown by tying the ties in the back next
Don a face mask or respirator if using a
face mask with ear loops place each loop
over the ears then grasp the nose piece
of the mask and bring it to cover the
bridge of the nose
then mold the nose piece of the face
mask with the fingertips of both hands
by starting at the bridge of the nose
and work outward toward the cheekbone
then grasp the nose piece of the face
mask and pull the bottom of the mask
under the chin if using an n95
respirator hold the respirator in one
hand with the front of the respirator
touching the inside of your hand the
metal nose piece should rest near the
fingertips
be sure the top and bottom straps of the
respirator are hanging down below your
hand and are not tangled or twisted take
the respirator and place it over your
nose mouth and under the chin hold the
respirator in place with one hand use
your free hand to place the straps on
your head it's very important the straps
rest on your head and are not
overlapping or
first take the top strap of the
respirator and place it just past the
top of your head above the ears then
take the bottom strap of the respirator
and place it around the bottom of the
head
just below the ears and then make sure
the straps are not overlapping or
twisted to ensure a proper seal of the
respirator around the nose area use the
fingertips of both hands to bend the
metal nose piece around the nose
starting in the center and working your
way outward on each side now perform a
seal test place both hands over the
respirator take a sharp breath in and
make sure that the respirator is sealing
over the face during this inhalation
keep both hands on the respirator and
breathe out while breathing out feel for
any air leaking around the nose piece
and around the respirators perimeter if
air is leaking around the nose piece try
rebuilding the nose piece with both
hands and recheck the seal if air is
leaking around the respirators perimeter
try adjusting the straps and recheck
again making sure the respirator is not
being affected by any piercings facial
hair or glasses which could prevent a
proper seal if the respirator still
leaks after this you may need a
different size or type of respirator do
not use the respirator if a proper seal
has not been obtained next dawn a face
shield or goggles
if using goggles apply goggles over the
eyes make sure any straps or bands of
the goggles are secured around the head
and the goggles fit snugly but
comfortably then perform hand hygiene
again lastly dawn gloves by pulling each
glove over the hand and extending the
cuff of the gloves over the sleeves of
the gown now I want to show you when the
possible sequences you can use to Dolf
PPE one of the sequences you can use to
remove PPE would be first removing the
gloves followed by the gown then the
face shield or goggles then lastly the
mask or respirator when removing the PPE
you will be doing this inside the
patient care area however if you wore a
respirator the respirator will be
removed
once you leave the patient care area
first remove the gloves do not touch the
outside of the gloves because they are
considered contaminated to remove the
gloves start by taking your non-dominant
gloved hand to grab the other glove
around the cuff in the wrist area do
this by using a pinching motion to grab
it peel this glove off by turning it
inside out
and what it into a ball with your gloved
hand keep it securely in your gloved
hand then take the index finger of the
unloved hand and slide it carefully
under the cuff of the gloved hand and
peel the glove off the hand by pushing
the index finger forward against the
glove this will turn the glove inside
out dispose of the gloves next remove
the gown the front of the gown and
sleeves are considered contaminated
whereas the ties on the inside of the
gown are considered clean therefore
avoid touching the front of the gown and
sleeves carefully untie or break the
ties of the gown peel off the gown by
removing the thumbs from the inserts if
present and then move the shoulders and
arms up through the gown which helps
allow the gown to slide off the body
then from the inside with the assistance
of the arms roll the gown away from the
body by turning it inside out form it
into a ball and discard then perform
hand hygiene next remove the face shield
or goggles do not touch the outside of
the goggles or face shield because they
are considered contaminated
if goggles are used remove the goggles
by carefully grasping and lifting the
back band of the goggles over the head
dispose or clean the goggles /
facilities protocol then remove the mask
or respirator if a mask is worn the
front of the mask is considered
contaminated
therefore grasp the ear loops of the
mask with the fingertips and remove the
mask from the face discarded the mask /
facilities protocol and perform hand
hygiene if a respirator is worn the
doffing procedure is performed outside
the patient care area the front of the
respirator is considered contaminated
therefore removed by the straps grasp
the bottom strap of the mask and lift it
over the head then grasp
the top strap of the mask and lift it
over the head dispose or reuse the mask
/ facilities protocol then perform hand
hygiene okay so that wraps up this video
on how to don and doff PPE and don't
forget to check out the other videos in
this nursing skills series